in this episode of things I learned
about loud spanner we look at right
patching to help a database specialist
accelerate their data load will we find
the right strategies for higher
throughputs stay tuned to find out in
the previous episode I helped my friend
Anna and her company pile of gadgets and
online shop for gadget friends we were
able to solve a hot spotting issue
during their data load that kept the
throughput low and that loud spanner
instance underutilized by choosing new
well distributed primary keys for the
tables we saw an increase in throughput
and utilization now we are going to see
if we can improve the data load
performance even further the data load
app which reads records from CSV files
and writes them to cloud spanner was
writing only one row per transaction
since our goal is to load data as fast
possible loading with a single row per
transaction doesn't sound like the
optimal solution it seemed obvious to
batch as many rights as possible
together to see a conservable throughput
boost while staying below transaction
limits of course the records we were
loading are fairly small so we increase
the batch size to a thousand rows per
transaction and expect that much higher
throughputs due to the reduced line
server communications and transactional
wed surprisingly we only saw a bit more
than doubling of our rights to put fifty
thousand rows instead of the previous 20
thousand rows per second don't get me
wrong more than doubling the support is
great but we wanted to see if we can
improve this even further as it turns
out we were still missing a step to get
the real benefits of batching the roll
set were patched together have well
distributed primary Keys the ones we
introduced in the previous episode to
fix the hot spotting issue during data
load that means writing 1000 of those
rows with well distributed primary keys
in a single transaction ends up
involving many many table splits as you
know a table is split based on size and
load patterns in ranges of rows ordered
alphabetically by primary key the
responsibility for this split is then
distributed among the available compute
nodes where each split is controlled by
exactly one node now when we write to
multiple splits in a single transaction
cloud span on
to coordinate between all the nodes that
are responsible for these splits for
that it needs to obtain locks and CLI
say access for all outstanding
transactions writing to any of these
splits using the two-phase commit
protocol
this means the benefits of having
multiple rolls in one transaction are
reduced by coordination overhead and
cured by spanning multiple splits armed
with this knowledge of the inner
workings of cloud spanner we needed a
way to reduce the number of splits
accessed by each transaction to gain the
maximum benefit of batching we went back
to our Lauria program and modified it to
load a large number of rows into cash we
then sorted these rows alphabetically by
primary key the same way the table
splits are ordered and partition them by
our chosen batch size from there we
created one transaction for each of the
partitions some might ask here
then we just introduced math distributed
primary keys to avoid hot spotting in
the previous episode and now we are
sorting right the trick here is that the
ordered petitions are distinct in the
primary key ranges they write to
spending fewer table splits and sewers
causing less contention during writes as
you can see in the graph this improves
our load performance significantly to
about 120,000 rows per second a six-fold
increase to very start from now to find
the optimal load performance we have to
keep a couple of limitations in mind
besides optimal size ranges for
transactions between 1 to 10 megabytes
there is a strict limitation of 20,000
mutation per transaction mutation what
is that a mutation has a special meaning
here where any modification of a single
cell in the table or index accounts for
one mutation except if you delete a
range of rows so for example if you have
a table with five columns and an index
defined on three of those columns
including the primary key columns each
insert of a row accounts for 8 notations
now if you don't want to write all these
logic into your own data loader you can
use the cloud dataflow connector for
cloud spanner the connector does Soaring
partitioning and scaling out writes
automatically for you
check out the sample source code we
linked in the description to learn more
about it after all these data load
optimizations my friends company pile of
caches was now happy with the load
performance and started to look into how
to optimize apps for scalability and
performance unfortunately we are out of
time in this episode so stay tuned for
our next one where we show how to design
our transactions for scalability and
performance
[Music]
you
[Music]